Okay, I don't know what leading indicators matter before closed project data is available.
I don't know what that means. What does a healthy first 90 days look like? Well, I mean, healthy
first 90 days as we get their website launched, if we start getting them leads because we fast
tracked some social ads or Google ads, then that'd be great too. But 90 days is not a
lot of time. Six months is a good amount of time to get things rolling. What common failure
patterns do builders repeat before asking for help doing it themselves? Walk me through
one builder example, starting the problem, big orange work and the change observed. So
typically, I'll do the one of our builders, they were trying to do all their marketing
in house, I believe I don't think they had anybody outside, they were going to do a home
drama. And the thing with home drama is you get literally 30,000 people walking through
your show home in two weekends. And then you've got 30,000 leads that you have to
figure out what to do with. And those are mostly not marketing qualified, but it's
still a good idea to sift through them. So we helped them with an email nurturing
series on that, we did their website before the show, so that when people walked through,
and then they went back later and search for this buyer, they were more impressed with their
website. So, you know, we're getting them more leads coming through the door. So that's kind
of how that rolls out. And that's the ideal, right? How we may use that example, quote,
paraphrase. Sure, you can paraphrase it. Which page direction feels most like big orange?
What should we combine and who gives final approval? Oh, that's the ones you wanted to
show us. That would be Margie and Paula for sure.
Yeah, I bet they'll say the cinematic one that I did, it was just like a little bit
more nuanced, there were a little bit more of the elements, I think that they were looking
for. So I bet they'll go with that one. Okay. All right. Well, it sounds like you have the
answers to those questions that you were looking to do. Okay, I do. And then I will send you
out. Sometimes it takes a little bit for these recordings to download, but I'll email
them down when I've got them. Yeah, I was gonna say my model is so good. Honestly,
it might know if it was admitted into this call, but I'm not I don't think it was,
but it surprises me sometimes. And it'll be like, hey, here's your entire meeting
transcript. And this is the next deliverables we need to do. I'm like, okay, that's funny. So
yeah, no, I'm really, I really appreciate. Excuse me, I have a recipe voice this morning,
but I really appreciate your time, Janice. And especially on a Friday, especially on a
Friday. And you know, I'm really excited, you know, just finish this project, because this was
like one of the very last things was like, you know, just getting this interview, getting all
these questions together, kind of baking it into this. And so I anticipate I will be done by next
week at some point. Okay, prior to my call, I'm calling them I believe on September 3. Okay,
so Margie showed me the project outline that she had, which was, I think she had asked for the
pillar page, some supporting pages, and then some yes, okay, okay, yes. So that's the very next
steps is kind of just getting all of that together. So I anticipate but definitely by the weekend,
next week, Friday, I would say I'll be hopefully fully totally done supporting articles, proper
keywords, like a CSV of all the keywords I found, which I already have. I have a lot of stuff
already done, basically, but then yeah, I'll let you guys be the the judge, the jury, and you know,
the last one, as they say, and I'm looking forward to talking to them.
Sounds good. All right. I will email you these recordings when I have them.
Great. Thank you. Have a great weekend. Yep. Bye bye. Bye.